just coming in I would do this thing
that I learned from DICE where I gotta
stand up for this yeah it's like four
people in a circle yeah and then like
let's say you guys all talking to your
Bobby stand up stand up but let's say
the tables not here yeah I never was
talking and I'll just go like I was
coming it's not like you even stayed out
of his way you really like no work yeah
let me [ __ ] go quick now the masseur
the dice also has a thing where where if
if people ask because back then there
was no cellphones
yeah and they would have like these
portable ones or whatever cameras yeah
cameras right and they he would go if he
people wanted to photo with them he'd
make us take it yeah but we had to crop
him out of it
who's so weird right so we would shoot
it and then when they got the film back
guys wouldn't be in it no their face
like this so you'd have to angle it and
get his shoes right the first time you'd
even tell me that was happening he was
like yeah I'll take a pictures you never
took pictures I'll take a picture with
you yeah re re you take the picture he
hands me like this and then I took it
and I didn't know and they left he goes
did you give me in it at all
no it's a good boy yeah I mean Hugh you
just knew I signed it so many dice
autographs were like all right sent to
the bath like are you sign it like
you're right here yeah you could just do
it I mean one day I was working the door
and he came up to me Ching we're going
to Vegas and I just they just let me
leave with him Wow Vegas with dice right
and you called you bad luck right oh my
god for [ __ ] that's another one yeah
I worked the door right first of all
he's called me Ching yeah for 15 [ __ ]
years yes I love the guy like it's Lee
it's all so stereotypical man I put the
effort yeah but then he goes it's as
chi-ching your money no
racist right so he goes gambling in the
Bellagio Mirage and he lost a half a
million dollars with them within 12
hours and I had no money at the time and
he said if I come up you're gonna get
like 10% of my money
because he thought I was good luck so I
was sitting next to him we have him
losing all this [ __ ] money he would
do 10,000 bets well III didn't have a
bank account yeah right and then when he
lost all that money we flew back he
didn't talk to me for years and he told
everyone that I was bad luck you're
cooler I mean the [ __ ] that I had the
[ __ ] deal with brawl right no I Ching
sorry change yeah yeah and then one day
out of the blue after five years of not
talking to Ari
I get a call from you yeah and what was
it well I sort of just got why call what
happened I got the number from Brenna's
II see why I was like hey what's Bobby's
number and he gave me your number one
number off as if he'd say I don't wanna
get involved
I've never enough to be like I was like
it's pretty much is this still his
numbers when I gave one off was like
that's definitely not one off them his
number
I know it's I've had the same number for
her birthday don't say it he's gonna
have to edit it out Wow
good memory that's incredible dig that
out yeah in your life I was like okay
the rage wasn't there anymore and I was
still acting on it but it was like
unbasic going over to him and like
you're so stupid
stop being fun yeah there's a passion
behind that the feelings for Natasha
were so gone right links for him
persisted longer than your hatred you
know yeah yeah and uh maybe it's a stuff
maybe not but like oh one time you said
yeah no no it wasn't it was it no it was
coholic s-- you thought it was a meeting
that was speaking at but it was a show
called the alcoholics for AAA oh and our
egos I'm gonna show up
- that thing it's a show but all AAA
people doing it in front of 800 I
thought it wasn't a meeting forgiveness
B and he goes um I'm gonna show up I'm
gonna [ __ ] up your speech yeah that's
what he said
so I had gone but I didn't know where my
sponsor at I'm Ritchie and all his spawn
C's have photos of re they're walking
around this [ __ ] auditorium to see if
they see this [ __ ] guy I'm at home I
mean that's the kind of heartache this
guy [ __ ] you know I wanted to do
what's the apology step was the ninth
step that's I was I was gonna like way
to talking about hey Bobby what about
apology have you done that because I
mean I haven't heard anything I'm
waiting for that number nine okay so in
the whole time you never actually said
hey I'm so sorry I [ __ ] up Bobby
didn't have that in him back then he was
just like what me it wasn't his blame
was ice
it was never Bobby's fault nothing was
everybody stop for a second alright yeah
the theory behind it was then thing that
he told me was is that I set them up
that's what I thought no no but more
anger was about there was a the whole
time never told me you would listen to
that you would hear because watches love
letters and I was like are all you see
yeah that's okay there you go
finally sorry I mean you know so I'm
gonna apologize let me apologize in the
realest way let me take my hand off the
number nine here's the thing there's no
justification for it okay and this is
wrong but did my what I was feeling then
was because you know when I got under
man it wasn't good for me in the
beginning to get on there yeah I mean I
when I was on they wouldn't put me on I
had problems that's why really what I
was complaining about yeah yeah it was a
terrible thing and I got felt like I was
caught in between this thing and I was
protecting my own ass and that was wrong
I should have been more upfront and
honest and I [ __ ] up it's hard to have
the hey man that's my friend's
girlfriend
yeah and listen you do whatever you want
don't probably show me this [ __ ]
yeah I should have done that yeah I
didn't yeah I didn't do it and um yeah I
I apologize it yeah I should have done
that and I by the way my relationship
with him is none who Ron what happened
to him so where did Canada and he is
like okay but when they're too deep
yeah right yeah Natasha's like fabulous
yeah yeah so he just calls me out of the
blue
do we have lunch or why don't what
happened so I called him I got his
number what I saw him I saw Bobby in the
front hallway the store holding court
you know five years later yeah
and then I just didn't have the energy
to go in there and be like and break it
up him having talking with friends and
so I just turned and I walked I walked
back into the room and went finds
another crowd then I was like well
there's a three other people there that
I would have liked to talk to and I'm
walking away from Mike conversation that
I want over this anger I don't even have
anymore and it was just like you know
just moments of realization where you're
like what am i doing now we're gonna
change my life yeah so I was just gonna
call got your number and I texted you
and I was like he's just so Bobby's not
really like no it's his cousin yeah I
could sort of believe that I was I could
see Bobby just giving his phone to
somebody this is a guy who got his car
towed and then just never paid the total
bills and then eventually just took it
they took his car who pre a new car
brand-new two weeks two weeks old and
then they just it was just because I
didn't know how throwaway zone and then
it's like just have it okay yeah so I
could see him I could see him just give
me his phone to somebody and I was like
oh well can you tell Bobby that uh
Ari Shaffir this guy knows wants to talk
to him find his number or something and
then you were like I think he really
liked yet it's Bobby okay but I was like
hey man I think it still works something
long months like I don't want to fight
anymore I get it I put you a bunch of
times you don't have to talk to me I
understand if you don't want to but I'm
done being mean to you I'll avoid you
stay away
if you want to be friends that's fine
too but I totally got other way but I'm
done being hateful towards you yeah and
then one when I saw you I punched you
right in the [ __ ] face you didn't see
a comment how was it when he when he
contacted me it was it so crazy how an
apology could just you could just stop
stuff and it it went right back to what
it was I think in many ways it was that
go of I hadn't have no resentment of
that at all and we've worked together
I've done a show a couple of times and
on live shows and stuff and we actually
did one you know version of his show
with Natasha Steve for me sorry doing
the story Begley for his show so comics
loveth yeah so it so to me it's like you
know under the bridge it's something
that happened I've had wars with a lot
of people you wouldn't show up the first
time first time I asked to do the show
he's like yeah okay and there's a I
stopped I stopped getting return text
from him there's after we're already
friends again yeah yeah I don't think
Bobby's gonna come and I was like dude
what the [ __ ] are you coming in he goes
I can't I have a new girlfriend yeah and
he was like I can't talk about Dockers
public with hookers I can't okay yeah
she knows everything
yeah yeah it's always better now they
let everything out of it in the
beginning though you have to hide this
yeah release at the time well I think it
was a month into us dating and I came
into under two months after and I'd
never been to his house before he always
just came to Long Beach to see me I come
in here and it was just it wasn't even a
livable like habitable place it was just
a mound of shoes in here there was
nothing yeah so I was like you know what
I'm going to fix you fix ya I'm gonna
fix you and while fixing this entire
place I must have found about 90 to 92
pictures of just him spreading hookers
butt cheeks apart pic skirts not 92 if
you're listening and I was watchin
listen
alright there's about four
[Music]